sham y llegó a eeuu hace ocho meses
este es un té afgano que me trajo un
amigo desde afganistán
este ex oficial de las fuerzas
especiales afganas sólo pudo rescatar
este traje tradicional pastún
algunos recuerdos de su vida militar
y fotos
este es mi padre y este es un amigo muy
cercano pero también mi jefe y el jefe
del estado mayor del ejército el general
a meta
pero sã me salvó lo más importante
su hijo de 2 años su mujer y su hermana
todos condenados a muerte por los
talibanes ha conseguido cambiarse de
ropa después de un par de semanas
un piso prestado por el estado de
maryland
y un trabajo en un restaurante de
washington un buen comienzo para una
nueva vida gracias a joseph y él también
es un refugiado afgano que llegó a eeuu
en la década de 1980 durante la guerra
contra los soviéticos
qué consejo puede darle trabajar duro al
final dará sus frutos para una nueva
vida pero una que sami claramente no
eligió
un mensaje más es un amigo que me
pregunta cómo puede salir de afganistán
pero no puedo hacer nada por él y eso
que me ruega que lo ayude
solo en washington hay miles de personas
como sham y miles de personas que tienen
que reinventar sus vidas aquí en esta
américa que no conocen sobre todo
después de haber llorado la pérdida
definitiva de un afganistán democrático